après s'est mobilisée de sochaux
klitschko à l'économique et pour les
tirs de sérieuses en 2014 la chanteuse
beyoncé se lancer dans une tournée
mondiale intitulé mi6 carter shaw sur
l'écran géant derrière la scène on
pouvait lire en lettres capitales le mot
féministe suivi d'une définition la
chanteuse s'autoproclamer porte parole
de la cause et le fait est que cela a
marché
beaucoup de personnes et surtout les
femmes ont vu dans ses textes ses
performances live et ses clips une forme
de célébration de la femme de son corps
de son pouvoir
personnellement ça m'a toujours frappé
qu'il puisse être considéré comme une
icône féministe toutes les féministes ne
seront pas d'accord avec le discours de
la star mais il faut bien avouer que
beyoncé a réussi à incarner pour le
grand public une forme de luxe ministre
pourtant dans good run the world girls
ce clip qui compte presque 400 millions
de vues sur youtube
si on oublie le texte un instant qu'ils
nous quittent donc que les femmes
dirigent le monde on voit exactement le
contraire
un groupe de femmes parfois à terre
jambe levée en porte jarretelles faisant
ça c'est un groupe d'hommes des hommes
bien mieux préparés qu'elle pour diriger
le monde
ils sont armés protégés de casques et de
boucliers avec de bonnes chaussures
après un flot d'imagés subliminales où
la femme est exposé à ce berger encerclé
le clip se termine par ce plan où les
femmes font le salut militaire qui n'est
même pas rendus par les hommes
conclusion les femmes ne dirigent pas le
monde
elles subissent tous les ressorts visuel
de la domination masculine
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour un
nouvel épisode de la modernité un
épisode vous allez le voir qui colle
particulièrement à l'actualité puisque
on va parler de la femme et de l'image
de la femme
posté des images cette domination se
manifeste de nos jours avant tout dans
la publicité les myriades de photos de
femmes sont destinés à faire consommer
on parle bien de femme objet les femmes
sont la plupart du temps photographier
et habillés par des hommes elles sont
tour à tour égérie de produits de luxe
mu d'artistes
mais est ce là véritablement une place
de marque une forme d'émancipation pour
les femmes n'ont certainement pas bien
au contraire même et sans entrer dans
une analyse poussée des publicités
actuelles on va pointer quelques uns des
aspects les plus récurrents de notre
manière de montrer les femmes que ce
soit à la télé ou dans les magazines
papiers la femme est le plus souvent
représenté seul et sans décor ça veut
dire qu'on ne peut pas la représenter
dans l'espace et dans le temps
il n'y a qu'à regarder la différence de
traitement hommes femmes pour la vente
d'un même produit pour s'en rendre
compte
la femme est souvent représentée dans un
canapé ou en position basse au niveau
des animaux de la saleté coup chez elle
peu moins se défendre étendu sur un lit
en pleine journée ce n'est pas pour se
reposer c'est pour exprimer une
disponibilité sexuelle au contraire un
homme est toujours situé dans un décor
précis qui suggère une activité
professionnelle ou de détente
si la femme est dans une pièce type
salon ou cuisine
cette pièce sera vides ou quasiment
vides vous trouverez un accessoire au
maximum un frigo un aspirateur
le but étant de supprimer toute
référence au travail et à l'effort
on ne représente jamais la femme en
train d'en baver dessus et de froncer
les sourcils et ça depuis au-moins
l'antiquité les éléments décoratifs des
bâtiments en témoignent les cariatides
femmes et les atlantes hommes traduisent
ses codes
les atlantes sont toujours en train de
forcer par muscles sont contractés ils
font la gueule
normal c'est lourd
les cariatides elles ont beau avoir le
toit du louvre sur la tête elles ne
montrent aucun signe de fatigue
elles sont détendus et toujours bien
coiffée l'homme est un héros il plie
sous l'effort la femme est un ornement
sois belle et tais toi en sommes donc qu
on récapitule un peu notre bonne femme
là est un corps sans muscles offert
d'une tranquilité sans borne
bien au chaud dans sa maison et si par
un heureux hasard un lien à sortir de
chez elle pour travailler elle est
encadrée non pas par un mais par
plusieurs hommes et ça n'est pas propre
à notre société contemporaine
les images de femmes sont partout tout
le temps
manipulés par les hommes pour les hommes
prenons un exemple emblématique d'une
toute autre époque
les statuettes préhistorique la
préhistoire nous a livré une quantité
importante d'objets représentant des
femmes ou le sexe féminin en particulier
ceux qu'on appelle les vénus ces petites
statuettes en bois ou en argile très
connus pour leurs cendres imposante
marquée au niveau des seins des fesses
et du bas ventre un peu comme beyoncé
beaucoup d'archéologues y ont vu le
symbole de la fertilité de la maternité
de l'existence d'une déesse mère et même
d'un matriarcat original c'est à dire un
pouvoir détenu par les femmes dans leur
esprit être représentée est une marque
d'importance si les femmes était
sculptée en milliers d'exemplaires
c'était donc qu'elles devaient être les
patronnes les taulières du bled c'est
notre reiss à nous
un archéologue du futur qui étudierait
notre époque pourraient d'ailleurs
conclure à partir des tonnes de vestiges
de panneaux publicitaires de magazines
et de compte instagram que les femmes
21e siècle régissent le monde
mais bon après tout pourquoi pas hein
pourquoi les femmes de la préhistoire
n'aurait elle pas été le mieux loti
pourquoi ne serait-ce pas l' indice d'un
matriarcat primitif la réponse est
simple parce que le matriarcat ça
n'existe pas n'en déplaise aux férus du
girl power primitif comme marie rage une
boutade qui voient en ces statuettes la
force créatrice de la femme mais de
toutes les sociétés humaines connu
aucune n'est dirigée par des femmes à
chaque fois le pouvoir public appartient
aux hommes il y à des sociétés qu'on dit
matrilinéaire ou le lignage et les biens
sont transmis par la mère mais c'est
tout le matriarcat ça n'existe pas à
part dans certains mythes chez les grecs
ce sont les amazon ou encore chez les
iroquois toutes les décisions
importantes dans les sociétés sont
prises par des hommes pour des hommes et
une image n'y échappe pas
après avoir critiqué l'idée du
matriarcat que penser d'un culte
ancestral à une déesse mère dans des as
mer il ya deux termes ds une divinité
dont qui veillent sur nous et à qui on
doit rendre culte
et puis l'autre terme mère qui renvoie à
la possibilité de donner la vie ou non
lorsqu'on découvre ses statuettes pour
la première fois au proche et
moyen-orient lors de fouilles
archéologiques
on pense tout de suite qu'il s'agit
d'objets de culte à une ds une déesse
qu'on aime associer aux récoltes et de
manière générale à l'agriculture en
oubliant au passage que ce type de
représentations existe depuis le
paléolithique période comme vous le
savez où l'agriculture n'existe pas or
lorsqu'on regarde de plus près le
contexte de découverte de ces statuettes
rien ne permet de prouver qu'elles sont
liées à une quelconque religion
elles sont la plupart du temps trouver
en mauvaise état en périphérie de
l'habitat et pas dans des temples
pour en finir avec nos venus que nous
dit l'anthropologie sur leur rôle
pourquoi les hommes sculpte des femmes
bien en chair si ce ne sont ni des chefs
ni des ds pour l'anthropologue alain
testart oui je sais encore lui mais que
voulez vous son travail est génial mais
malheureusement peu vulgariser les
femmes sont bonnes à penser les regarde
et procure un plaisir leurs seins la
hanche leur baisse stimule l'imagination
regardons les attentivement on voit que
la plupart du temps la vulve et marquait
d'un trait 1,6 et mais ceux qui se
démarque le plus de ces pièces sont les
saints et surtout les fesses par les
fesses n'ont rien à voir de la fertilité
c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait les bébés
drôle l'image que celle de la femme à la
fois dépendante des hommes et maîtresse
de maison
j'aurais pu parler des thèses de pierre
bourdieu développer dans le livre la
domination masculine
mikit a parlé des femmes autant vous
présenter un travail tout aussi
intéressant sur la question est fait par
une femme
celui de l'historienne michelle perrot
elle explique que la société organise la
différence des sexes
la femme est vu comme un manque déjà
chez les philosophes grecs et un
réceptacle une statuette mal cuites pour
aristote la femme est inférieur par sage
génitalité qui inférieur et angoissante
son sexe fait peur le sens des règles
nourri de nombreuses superstitions en
avait déjà rapidement parlé au sujet des
baruya dans une précédente vidéo
enfin le pouvoir qu'ont les femmes de
donner la vie ou non renforce les
craintes à leur éclat si un mot pouvait
résumer l'image de la femme se serait
ambiguïté dans le traitement des images
la femme et à vide ou frigide bénéfiques
ou maléfiques dans la religion retrouve
aussi tout un panel de symboles qui
renvoie cette ambivalence la périodicité
le temps cyclique qui sont liées à la
maternité
et puis le secret et le mystère autour
de leur sexualité
une sexualité inconnu et méconnu avec la
crainte de ne pas satisfaire sa
partenaire
la domination masculine on va le
rappeler ici est une construction
sociale historique mais qui a des
répercussions très concrètes sur nos
vies tant sur celle des femmes que celle
des hommes d'ailleurs cependant croire
qu'on est parti d'une période dirigées
par des femmes
depuis que petit à petit le pouvoir a
été transmis aux hommes est un schéma
qui ne tient pas croire au matriarcat
c'est accepter l'idéologie de la
domination masculine après avoir dit
tout ça là qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
les femmes sont plus nombreux sur terre
vivent plus longtemps et sont très
actifs dans des tas de domaines
elles sont à la fois sur représentés
dans le monde publicitaire et al'inverse
qui manque cruellement de visibilité
dans les domaines scientifique
l'histoire par exemple reste écrite le
plus souvent par des hommes et
l'histoire est un récit ce sans fin il
faut donc en continu et l'écriture si
nous les femmes manquons de visibilité
nous disposons à présent et à la
différence des époques antérieures des
mêmes outils que les hommes un clavier
pour écrire une connexion internet pour
s'informer
il faut que les femmes écrivent les
laisse une trace et se bougent les
fesses pour ne pas tomber dans l'oubli
en collant une image imposé par une
société patriarcale et se fige et du
même coup dans un éternel mythe
cet épisode est terminé merci à tous de
l'avoir regardé
n'hésitez pas à le partager c'est une
très bonne manière de soutien la chaîne
et puis si vous voulez vous pouvez aussi
soutenir financièrement sur la
plateforme tipi vous trouverez le lien
en barre d'infos et sur la page
d'accueil de ma chaise je vous remercie
une dernière fois et je vous dis à la
prochaine salut
[Musique]